in Israel a nationwide uproar over plans
to make the Supreme Court their less
independent has quieted down at least
for now opponents of the right-wing
government there in Israel do say they
will continue to protest these judicial
changes after the Prime Minister said
last night he will put the measure on
hold at least for a few weeks MTS tayab
is there
violence on the streets of Tel Aviv
hours after prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu bowed to intense public
pressure by announcing his plans to
overhaul the Judiciary would be paused
but as protesters for and against the
reforms Clash bitterly with each other
it was clear the Divide within Israeli
Society remains deep and more dangerous
than ever we're taking their power that
they got democratically and they're
ruining our Democratic systems forever
three months of mass demonstrations came
to a head on Sunday after Netanyahu
fired the defense minister of triggering
a chaotic 24 hours which saw massive
spontaneous protests outside his
residence in Jerusalem at general strike
which all but ground the country to a
halt and opposition members of knesset
bitterly confronting the government
described as the most extreme far-right
in Israel's history over plans they're
calling a power grab
if passed the judicial overhaul would
allow for a simple majority of lawmakers
to override almost any Supreme Court
rulings and that politicians appoint
justices eroding one of the nation's few
checks and balances over the government
critics say but the underlying issues
that have so polarized this nation still
remain
[Applause]
[Music]
future of this nation is far from over
with senior figures of netanyahu's
far-right government insisting this
overhaul will become law Nate
in Israel thank you